>> PLEASE BE SEATED.EM, I DETA
A VERDICT.
MB J WILL NOW
PERECORDOF THE FOURTJUDICIAL DI.
STATE OFF , RTISTRIC OOTA PLAYOK
MI DEFENDANT.
THE COURT FI 27 CR-2012646.
WE, THE JURY IN THOVE ED MANNER
UNINTENTIONAL SECOND-DEGREE
MURDERLETTING A FELONY
FIND THEEFEED TO THIS 20th
DAY OF APRILUROR FOREPERSON, JU
NUMBER9.
WE THE AVETIO COUNT
TWO, THIRD-DEGREE MURDER FIN
E .S 20th
DAY OF APRIL, 2021 AT  P.M.
GNED BY THE JU
JUROR  CAPONT
THREE.
WE THE JURY IN T A
ENTITLED MANNER ASO COUN
THREE, SECOND-DEGREE
MANSLAUGHTER, CULP
NEGLIGENCE CREATING ANONABLEHE
DEFENDANT GUILTY.
THIS VERDICT AGREED TOS
DAY OF APRIL, EMURY, I'M NOW GO
ARE AND CORRECT . THESE
YOUR NUMBER TWO, ARE TR
CORRECT VERDICT?
>> YES.
>>IM NUMBEFINE?
>> YOUR NUMBER 19, ARE THESE T
>>NUER THESE
YOUR TRUE AND CORRECVERDICTS?
>> YES.
>> JUROR NUMBER 44E THESE
YOUR TRUE CORRECT TS?
>> JUROR NUMBER 52, ARE THESE
YOUR TRUE AND CORRECT VEES.
>> JUROR NUMBER 55, ARE THESE
YOUR TRUE AND CORRECT VERDICTS?
END CORRECT 79, ARE THES
VERDICTS?
>> YES.
>> JUROR NR , ARTHE
YOUR TRUE AND CORRECT VERDIC?
>>
>> JUROR NUMBER 89, IS THI
ARE THESE YOUR TRUE AND CORREC
VERDICTS?
>> YES.
>>UR, ARE THESE
YOURVERDICTS?
>> YES.
>> JUROR NUMBER 92E RRT VERDIC
>> SO SAY YO S YOU
>> YES>> MEMBERS OF THE JUI
THAT THE VERDICTS AS READ
ECT THE RY ANDFID
ANK YOU ON BEHAL
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
MINNESOTA FOR NOT Y
SERVICE BUT HEAVY DUTY JURY
WHAT I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
THE DEPUTY
INTO YOUR USUAL OMN W MINUTE
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND TO ADVISE
YOU FURTHER, SO ALL RISE FOR THE
.
. THE GUILTY VERDICTS 'RE GOING
WITHIN ONE WEEE COURT WILL ISSUN
E BLAKELY  THE FACTUALEEK AFTEA
RETURNABLE IN FOUR, AND WE
WILL ALSO HAVE BER
YOU GET E I S FROM
NOD THENHTM NOW WE WILL HAVEWE'A
HEDULING MOTION ON BEHALF OF
THE  YOUR  THETE WOULD VE TO HA
M  CUSTODY.
>> THE BAIL IS REVOKED, BOND I E
MAO HE HENNEPIN COUNTY ERIFF.
THANK YOU.
.
>> SO THERE YOHAVE IT, LESS
THAN TEN MINES, GUILTY ON ALL T.
GUILTY SECOND-DEGREE M
GUILTY THIRD-DEGREE MURDER AND
AWAITING THESEL THREE COUNTSBAC.
DI
FRONHICLOSELY AS AE.
USTICE BEEN SERVED, AND
N SEE THE TIM
E OW AMERICA FLSM SU PEOPLO ARE
WATCHING ALL OVE
OR WATCHING ALL OVER THE WORLD
ON THEIR DEVIC GETTING
I AM
JUSTICE ON ALL COUNTS.
THE ATTORNEY FORRU
ME ATA, WOD HESAYS GUILTY.
PAINFULLY EARNED JUSTICE HAS
FINALLY ARRIR GEORGE
FLOYD'S .DICT IS A TURNING POIN
MEE D FOR W
ENFORCEMENT.
JUSTICE FOR BLACK AMERICA IS ST
D OUR AMITH
OUR LEGA FIERCJUSTICE FO
GEORGE, BUT IT DOES NOT EN. H.
WE HAVE TOTHLOSTICE IN POLIN LA
ENFORCEMENTABLE AND
PREVENT SO MANY OFJUSTIFIED KIL
THIS REMINDS ME IN SOMWAYS,
BUT IT  OF THE TENSION AND
THE ION AND THATWAS FELT DURG E
O.J. S, PEOPLE ON TH
OTHER PEOPLE WERE T REED INTO
ITSELF, AND IFT DIDN'T SPEAK
FOR ITSELF, WO
FI O A TG OFFICER,
E LA H
HOME FOR HIM WL  PRISON.
HISTORY THATRICA
COUNTS, SECOND-DEGRE,
O 40 YEARSWE DON K THAT,
R, 3YEM SECONDND MANSLAUGHTER,
MAXIMUM SENTENCE 10 YEARS,
DON'T KNOW IF HE'LL GET ALL THAT
BUT HE'S GOING TO JAIL F
ONG TIME.
>> FOR VIEWERS THE
LOCATION WHEEORGE FLOYD WARDERER
MURDER GATRE SEEING GEORGEFLOYDH
VERDICT.
>> O D, E
TO GK ABOUT THAT YOUNG
SHE ING.KNOWING WHATO DO B JUSH.
CAME AND --  MUNS WH
PLEADED ANTA
THEY DID THE RIGHTNG
T  THE RIGHT THING.
PEOPLE CALLED THE POCE
DID THE T EN THEREE
MAN THEY DID THE RND
WHEN PEOPLE HED  T
D THE THING AND PART O
THAT WE W GIRL.E GOT INVOLVED
SO MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS
DONE WAY.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
ITS D OF ANYINIS IS TH
CONGRESS?
THEY NEED TO ACT.E CHOKEHOL A
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
THAT NEEDS TCH
O DUTY TO INTERVENE FROM
THDE.
THAT NEEDS TCHAN REGISTRY FO
LIKE CHAUVIN
NOW WHEN YOU HAVE DY LIKE VES A
GHTING
THEM. SHOULD NE AGAIN.
ONE MA ME  GO.
SOMETIMES WHEN WE FI
E FIWE
WIN.
THE LE
>> WHEN YOU SAW DEREK CHAUVIN
PUTTING HIS HANDS  HIS
BACK BEINGUFFED D
OUT OF THE COURT, WHAT DOU
THINK?
>> JUSTICE.
DOS THAN WALK ANY KIDS WHOE
OUT OF COURTROOMS DCUFFS, WITH
YEARS ON SNITCH EVIDENCE
ONE KID TESTIFYING AGAINST
ANOTHER KID AND GO TO PRIS
YOU DON'T HAVEV CAMERAS AND DYN.
OVER ANDVER AGAIN.DERISON AND
THAT'S WHAT JUSTICS LI.
EOPLE -- ALL WE WANT
THE CE T THEWE
BUR  AND WHEN THEY BREAKHE
LA